the world looks on as russian president
vladimir putin launches a full-scale
attack on ukraine
and now it's becoming clear that he
intends to use his country's military
might in a bid to rewrite european
history the west meanwhile has been
imposing what have been described as the
toughest sanctions ever but putin is
clearly not impressed so is it time for
europe's democracies to face up to some
new and uncomfortable truths and perhaps
fight for their future on to the point
we ask ukraine under attack is europe
powerless against putin
[Music]
[Music]
well thanks very much for joining us
here on the show and my guests in the
studio include the historian eureka von
hiershausen who says
russian tanks invading ukraine teach us
one clear lesson we need a broad
collection of tools if we are to realize
our international responsibility
also with us is vandaline von paredo
from the economist magazine who believes
vladimir putin has damaged his country
the eu is still russia's biggest export
market
and western sanctions will hurt
and a warm welcome too to matthew
karnichinick chief europe correspondent
for politico
and matthew argues that russia's latest
invasion of ukraine illustrates the
failure of european and especially
german foreign policy which for years
has focused on trying to placate putin
thank you very much uh for being with me
today uh i'd like to begin with uh
ulrica
and uh vladimir zelinski the the
ukrainian president has come out and
said putin vladimir putin wants to
destroy ukraine is that going too far or
is that an accurate description of where
we are now
i would say
putin wants to destroy ukrainian
autonomy not the ukrainian nation as
such
but
of course what he's doing right now is
trying to re a revival of an imperial
idea of a great russia
tell me about the imperial idea of a
great russia
well in the 19th century the ukrainians
were used to uh
as as
to be called small russians you know
little russians whereas russians were
seeing themselves as great russians
and this is an idea of dependency which
putin wants to revive today which is
totally out of time
does does putin want to destroy ukraine
no i agree with them with rick i think
he wants to
[Music]
subjugate ukraine but but obviously not
destroy it he wants to maybe rule over
the country and make it part of greater
russia
but
but that doesn't mean that that
that it's going to be a destruction
it's been described as a tragedy a
catastrophe for europe
what do you say matthew
i i say it's a crime it's not a tragedy
a tragedy denotes something that has to
do with fate and what we're dealing with
here is is a criminal and it's it's
completely clear i disagree i think he
does want to destroy ukraine as a nation
he might not want to
you know bomb it into the stone age
but he wants to
remove the idea from people's minds that
ukraine
is an independent
nation
and i think this is a a continuation of
what we've seen in the past with the
soviet union they tried something
similar by you know the forced
russianization of
parts of of ukraine it's not an accident
that in in the don bass for example
where there are a lot of russian
speakers well why are there so many
russian speakers there one reason is
that uh this is a coal mining area that
the russians sent a lot of russians in
there decades ago to work in in the coal
mines and and in the industry um and i
think this is something that has a long
history there where they've tried for
generations the russians to dissuade
people from embracing
their ukrainian uh heritage and and he
sees himself i think in in this in this
tradition
you're nodding
i do oh
i'm ver i'm very concerned about the
extent to which vladimir putin is
i mean you talk about violence you talk
about criminal energy
vladimir putin is like a bully in the
school yard how do you deal with a bully
we know how to do that how do you deal
with vladimir
putin i think a big problem is that
europe but particularly germany has lost
sight of its responsibility and in
germany in the last 15 years there was a
path of germany first
and i think we have to redo that and to
take on our responsibility also on a
military dimension how does that work
matthew
you are the expats at work i mean it is
something that you can't do overnight
but now we're unfortunately
we're seeing the the errors of of the
past and especially germany's not just
the refusal to really invest in its
military or to to help ukraine um we're
also seeing the strategic errors that
germany made in supporting uh the north
stream projects in in my view even after
it was clear what putin was doing this
isn't something that happened overnight
with him he signaled already in 2007
what he wanted to do in a famous speech
at the munich security conference then
and a couple of months after he started
um implementing his plan with the cyber
attack on estonia which basically shut
down
their internet it was the first such
attack of its kind on on that scale and
he followed up a year later with the
attack on uh georgia and then uh crimea
and uh the the wars in in east ukraine
and beyond that of course what he's done
in syria libya the assassinations
including in berlin of uh you know a
chechen uh a rebel here alexi navarni
the germans sort of looked at that and
said well we still can talk to him we
still need dialogue with him this is the
only answer is dialogue and we're going
to continue to pursue these gas projects
with him because if we bring him into
the fold
then you know we're going to be brothers
basically and well that's turned out not
to be the case well
your question was how do you deal with a
with a bully and unfortunately the bully
understands the language of strength and
i agree with matthew we we haven't
really spoken that language we tried
and now even now in that recent crisis
we tried diplomatic channels i mean you
know one after the other emmanuel macron
olaf schultz the various foreigners they
all went to moscow they all tried they
were basically humiliated by putin and
by lavrov
and um and it didn't work the diplomacy
didn't work i do however think that
putin radicalized over the years i think
there was a time when maybe diplomacy
and and friendship could have worked you
know there was a famous putin speech in
the bundestag
where he says you know russia is
friendly russia is a friendly european
country
and um i think in a way we missed an
opportunity then but but now it's of
course far too late ricky you wanted to
add something
i think it also has to do something with
his obsession with history which has
been growing over the years and you were
mentioning the dates 2007 he was making
clear that safeguarding russian
minorities beyond the russian border is
one of his main duties
and then that became stronger 2013 and
2014 he announced crimea saying this is
part of russia and now last year we had
this
offset this paper which he sent to
german historians
exactly by now you all know this paper
where he made explicitly clear that
ukraine is part of greater russia
so i think his obsession with his
version of history has contributed to
that and this is also one argument why i
think it will not um
start to affect the baltic states this
is of course a question which we all are
questioning ourselves but i do not think
that he will start to occupy the baltic
states a because they are nato members
and b because they don't fit into his
version of great russia okay the world
according to vladimir putin let's just
have a listen to
one statement from the russian leader
whoever tries to interfere with us and
even more so to create threats for our
country
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate
and will lead you to such consequences
that you have never experienced in your
history
how do you deal with a bully that was
the question and uh matthew i think the
the answer is in that in in that
statement that we've just heard is that
we are dealing with uh
a nuclear option possibly well he's
leaving it to people's imagination
it's clear that russia has tactical
nuclear weapons that it could
use in a situation like this of course i
think he knows that if he were to do
that then he would be endangering his
own country's future but
you know he's clearly serious about
what's going on in in ukraine and
uh in a couple of weeks we'll we'll know
how successful
he he has been there and i think whether
he moves into the the baltics or not i
don't think that he's going to do that
right away but i think that it will lead
to a re-militarization of the eastern
flank of nato and this is going to be a
major shift in europe's security
architecture the most major shift since
the end of the cold war because up to
now the nato countries had agreed there
was a
agreement with russia not to permanently
station troops in the baltics or in the
former warsaw bloc countries i think
that's going to go out the window now
and we're going to see permanent nato
bases more american troops in in europe
again and especially on
that that eastern flank and all you need
to do is look at a map to see the
countries that border ukraine um so it's
going to be a much more dangerous
neighborhood than it has been i was
going to say uh vandaline this is uh
this is a very sensitive part of the
world with a very sensitive history tell
us a little bit about that as the
backdrop to what we're seeing now
because we are sitting here in germany
in berlin
the the which was where so many of the
crimes committed in this sensitive part
of the world they they started back
under the nazis absolutely and our our
nearest our closest neighbor is poland
and poland has of course historically
suffered a lot has suffered at german
hands and russian hands and the poles
feel very fragile very vulnerable
they've been arguing for for more help
from nato for for years and now you know
they were proven right and of course the
next line of defense in a way or the
closest you get are the baltic states
and also not only are they even closer
to russia and to ukraine but they are
also very small
so um and they've they've equally
suffered a lot
but from both sides always you know they
were always sandwiched between the
russians and the germans and
historically
and so of course it's it's a completely
different mindset in these countries
and and and i think they've been asking
for our support for years and we should
have probably been even more steadfast
than we have been but but now you know
just by the force of events it will
happen relatedly and uh and i suppose
one of the questions is is is
are the people of ukraine going to going
to we're talking about you know whether
the germans or nato will offer support
and what what shape or form that support
might be whether it might be of a
military nature what about the people of
ukraine themselves are they going to put
up a fight
against vladimir putin
i do think so
um if we look at the amount of
identification with the ukrainian nation
it has
increased
very much over the last 10 years also
due to the permanent aggression of putin
and if you look at how many people are
now recruited in this civilian force
which of course doesn't play a big
military role but it has a symbolic
role of you know
yeah i do think that there will be much
more identification even more than
before with the ukrainian nation and are
we talking about people uh taking to the
streets or are we talking about people
really engaging in civil disobedience
are we talking about you know a possible
insurgent war
i don't believe in that i do think that
more men will voluntarily
take up the arms within sort of regular
forces and this is what celensky has you
know asked people to do well let's just
let's just get a quick word from mr
silenski let's hear what he's been
saying and
how his mood is
ukraine
behind me stands ukraine
with its internationally recognized
borders
and it will remain the same no matter
what
no matter the statements and actions by
russia
just as we remain calm and confident
statement of intent a very strong intent
i think that the ukrainians are going to
fight one of the big questions here that
some of us have been looking at over the
past uh several weeks and wondering
about is what if it came to an invasion
what would putin's ultimate goal be and
i think there's
you know a theory sort of the consensus
of people i spoke to about this is that
he would try to basically divide the
country along the nipper river which
runs through kiev and then
you know basically keep or keep under
his control the the eastern part what
they call left bank uh ukraine and then
the the western part would uh you know
remain as a kind of a rump state and and
that is where you know you i think we'll
see in insurgencies or
something something similar to that
people will keep will keep fighting
there he's also moved into odessa
already which is a key black sea port
for ukraine most of its trade goes
through there it's also seen as the
pearl of the black sea it's very
important historically and culturally
for russia as well but if ukraine is
robbed of that then it's it's going to
be you know sort of squeezed
economically as well so it will need a
lot of western support and i suspect
that the united states and other nato
allies will be quite happy to uh
help uh finance uh some kind of an
insurgency i was going to say we haven't
mentioned the american perspective at
all on this so uh i mean you know people
are people right outside the european
theater might think well for the
americans this is happening in europe if
there is a war
and we
we see an invasion we see that perhaps
the beginnings of an occupation it'll be
in europe it'll be a long way from the
us but it's very important for the
americans
well european stability is very
important for the united states
obviously uh
for economic reasons for for a lot of
other reasons um the united states was
engaged in the cold war obviously for
for many decades in europe and i think
that
successive administrations in the united
states took their eye off the ball when
it comes to russia when it came to putin
and they uh misjudged him and they
didn't take the threat that he posed
seriously enough and that goes right up
to joe biden who thought that he could
concentrate on china and the threat that
the united states feels china now poses
to both the united states and and the
west and and leave russia to the
europeans but
this was also true under under trump
although he despite his reputation uh
supported more sanctions against uh
russia than
than anyone else
but also of of barack obama who
dismissed russia as a regional power
which was a slight i think that putin
neither forgot nor forgave and i don't
think anybody is looking at this
situation now and is saying that russia
is just a regional power
i think the mistake that's often made is
to sort of look at russia's gdp and say
well it's actually you know smaller than
italy's and hence it's it's it's you
know as as you said and just a regional
power but it's not you know it's the
biggest country in terms of its
geography in the world uh it has vast um
natural resources and it has nuclear
weapons so you know you cannot say it's
just the regional power and that that
you know we made that mistake i think it
was a misreading of the fact
you sound just a little bit or at least
you could be construed that you sound
like somebody in germany who has been
much criticized in the last week or so
the the the people who have tended to
over the years and more recently placate
is the word that is often used placate
vladimir putin
no i'm not in favor of that i think
that's a mistake i think the only
language we understand is is the
language of strength i think when we
should have done the opposite
but i but i also think um that
that that for for many years certainly
the americans but in a way also western
europe underestimated russia's intention
misread the intention and didn't quite
understand you know how serious putin
will is about rebuilding the greater
russia that he's dreaming about
there's a big debate in germany at the
moment about what uh to use a german
word but the words can sometimes be so
very evocative the the verhaftisch kite
of
of germans the german military in the
current in the current situation the
current crisis
is uh can you explain the the the debate
in the vehicle's guide for uh we have to
cut as far as i understand it's just
whether germany could even defend itself
could you know
could fight a war if you if you will i'm
not a
yeah the readiness exactly i'm i'm not a
military expert but from what i
understand the
so so bundesw not sure okay let's have a
look let's have a look at a report that
we have on the uh the situation in the
bundeswehr where there are several sort
of overlapping problems
they still exist the peace marches to
which pacifists in germany call but
they're not as big as they were in the
1980s when hundreds of thousands
demonstrated against the deployment of
american short and intermediate-range
missiles there are also still protests
at the annual swearing-in of bundespere
recruits
the bun despair germany's military has
shrunk in recent decades
from about 500 000 soldiers in the 1960s
only a third remained after the end of
the cold war
the enemy was no longer in the east
and national defense was no longer the
sole mission
instead german soldiers bought together
with the allies in afghanistan among
other places and alongside the french in
mali
both foreign missions are considered
more or less to have failed
bundeswehr equipment is inadequate
all there's a lack of transport capacity
only a small number of helicopters are
even operational
the americans in particular have long
complained that nato partner germany
invests far too little in its armed
forces
and further there seems to be a lack of
political strategy for the tasks of the
bundeswehr
is germany at war with its military
well that's one question is germany at
war with this military i think also i
mean the question is might be might be
is it time for germany to really beef up
its armed forces uh that's been a very
important debate and it's got uh it's
central to german's own credibility
i would agree
with um mrs robredo we really need to
speed up
in 2014 when putin annexed crimea
28 nato members agreed on spending two
percent of their gross product on
defense
and we are right now i think around 1.5
or so
so i think this is a strong
responsibility of germany to take up its
responsibility in a way and what i think
is we need a more broader how should i
say
maneuverability is that word exists in
english to have sort of different
political
um means of power a broader repertoire
of power in germany and not trusting
only an economy
to use its way but rather to use
political
military cultural and economic means
this is matthew about i mean for for for
most of us the people living here in
germany living in central europe uh
liberal democracy is what we cherish
liberal democracy is what we hold up as
sort of what we believe in in many many
ways uh the question is are we willing
to defend it
well you've had the luxury of not having
to defend it and i think that is part of
the problem here that there isn't really
a security culture in germany there are
in other parts of europe but in germany
in particular for the last 75 years or
so the country has lived pretty well
under the security or at least the
western part of the country under the
security umbrella provided by the united
states so people haven't had to worry
about these issues and germans have gone
about sort of looking at their own past
at world war ii the whole discussion
about
the um
as they call it sort of confronting
their past and so forth and this process
has i think turned people away in
general from all things military
which unfortunately has created a
situation where it is often looked at as
something sort of morally untoward to
want to go into the german army say and
that's one of the reasons now
that
the germans have a huge problem with the
resurgence of extremism in the ranks of
the bundeswehr of the german army
because the only people who really want
to go want to go for the wrong reasons
often so i think this is a much deeper
problem that is not just about money
it's about creating a culture and
helping people understand
why
military is
is necessary and i think that germans
have have really lost that
um i agree um with matthew i think in
the in the years after the war it was
probably
the right decision for germany to take a
very low profile militarily right and to
do to basically and i think the
americans then were very willing to
protect germany and to have germany live
under its umbrella but now you know
that's a long time ago and germany has
in a way just continued to do that um
because it was convenient because it
suited the pop
the gen the population the public
opinion
but things have to change and and the
rapid and the reputation of the
bundesliga is a big issue because if it
were better if it were like in america
or in france even you know then then
then it you know it would attract better
people it the bundeswehr wouldn't have a
problem to recruit people and the
problem of extremism which is a real
problem in the bundeswehr would probably
not be such a problem
and i would like to bring in the
historical dimension in this because one
of the arguments for not having enough
deterrence is of course world war ii
but if we look at it who suffered so
much where the ukrainians ukraine was
one of the main war theater in world war
ii deportations
the majority of
german spunks are biter forced labor
ukrainians so i don't see the argument
to be valid
and i think we have to really look at
the facts this is one of the strange
aspects i think of the dynamic between
germany and russia is that the germans
feel this historic debt to the russians
and this has sort of really infused this
entire debate over north stream two the
pipeline and other issues with russia
where the germans said well we have this
historic debt that we uh need to honor
and when we we need to give the russians
the benefit of the doubt but as you say
i think most germans aren't aware that
actually more ukrainians died as a
percentage of the total population then
russians more belarusians died as well
and and this is just something that's
not discussed here are germans are
europeans powerless powerless against
putin i think that they are powerless
for the moment i think they're going to
become much more reliant on the united
states again as a result of this and all
of these discussions in europe about
strategic autonomy are going to end very
quickly okay thank you for subbing it up
there we'll have to leave it there
thanks very much indeed for joining us
and if you've er
if we've given you plenty of food for
thought then do come back next time
until then bye bye and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you